Aujourd'hui pour ce nouvel épisode de "Dans son corps",
nous recevons un invité extrêmement cool et branché
qui vient nous parler de sa particularité à lui.
Il s'agit de :
Pierre Lapin.
Veste bleue, pas d'pantalon,
tu es sans doute Pierre Lapin.
T'es sérieux ? Parce que...
Pierre Lapin
Pierre est photographe vidéaste et streamer sur twitch.
Il anime la chaîne «Le Club» avec Guilhem de YouTube, entre autres.
- Salut Pierre
- Salut Julien
Alors quelle est ta particularité physique à toi ?
Hmm, alors j'ai une myopathie qui s'appelle dystrophie musculaire de Becker.
Qui est le petit cousin de la Duchenne,
qui est une des maladie des plus répandues et beaucoup plus grave que la mienne.
La dystrophie musculaire de Becker est une maladie rare causée par une anomalie génétique.
Elle ne touche que les garçons; le plus souvent pendant l'enfance ou à l'adolescence.
Et donc, du coup, c'est une maladie qui s'attaque aux muscles.
Donc avec une hyperfatigabilité, une destruction musculaire.
Puis, bah, c'est malheureusement dégénératif.
Je pense, j'ai une espérance de vie normale, semi-normale.
Et après, le seul truc maintenant depuis que j'ai grandis
c'est surveiller le cœur et tout ça.
Mais sinon c'est souvent les gros muscles, les cuisses, les mollets et voilà,
Donc faut que je sois vigilant à pas faire trop trop d'efforts.
La myopathie de Becker c'est une dystrophie musculaire,
c'est-à-dire un trouble du développement des muscles.
Elle entraîne une faiblesse principalement au niveau des jambes
mais aussi au niveau du cœur.
Comment tu as réagit quand tu t'es rendu compte que t'avais quelque chose de différent des autres?
Heu... Bah mal, *rigole*.
En fait, ça se déclenche un peu tard. Enfin, j'ai toujours été malade.
Enfin, tu naît malade mais ça se déclenche plus tard.
Moi, c’était je pense en CE2 donc je devais avoir huit ans.
Et donc là ça commence tout de suite,
bah t'es un peu une feignasse en sport donc le prof va le dire
et tout ça mais toi tu galères un peu, tu traînes de la patte, tu comprends pas trop pourquoi.
Donc, tu sens quelque chose changer en toi donc déjà tu le vis mal.
Et là, début des premières hospitalisations : tu comprends pas
tu te retrouves tout seul dans ta chambre et ça commence à être un peu difficile.
Même, tu vois tes parents un peu désespérés tout ça.
Et là c'est là ou s'enclenche.
Tout mon parcours hospitalier qui je pense,
j'peux le catégoriser de chaotique.
Donc ça commence donc, moi j'étais en Bretagne, donc ça commence à Lorient
un CHU basique donc on sait pas trop
on voit que j ai des muscles chelou
j'ai beaucoup de CPK, j explosait à 2000 comme si je faisait un infarctus et tout ça.
Donc on a commencer à vouloir faire des test donc j'ai eu mes première biopsies
donc on commence à m'ouvrir un peu à me charcuter pour savoir c'que j'ai donc là on part sur une
glycogénose,
onc voilà on part là dessus donc un allèle manquant
donc le sucre qu'est mal assimilé ou je sais pas quoi.
Ça change pas grand chose
ça avance pas, ils me renvoient à la Timone de Marseille
on fait les trucs comme ça
ils voulaient réutiliser mon muscles je sais pas pourquoi au final le service de St Paul l'avait perdu
donc il m'ont ré-ouvert
Donc anesthésie pas forcement générale donc une belle souffrance.
apporte rien c'était un vieux monsieur,et tout ça, donc on a un peu désespérer
là je dis ça, ça fait déjà trois quatre ans de maladie
Et après je part au CHU Hôtel Dieu de Nantes
où je découvre un magnifique professeur qui se décide
après l’auscultation basique de dire que ma mère
aurait le syndrome de Münchhausen
et que je ne serait pas vraiment malade et qu'elle m empoisonne et tout ça
Donc tout commence un peu a breacker dans ma tête
et dans la tête de mes parent je pense, je pense qu'il a un peu détruit beaucoup de vies la dedans
Et donc tout s écroule pour moi.
Donc je passe du statut «bah t es malade»
et après j'suis plus du tout malade et c est ma mère qui m empoisonne
ou je sais pas, et c'est là où tout le syndrome d'imposture
et tout ce qui va me rendre plus malheureux ou plus fucked up dans la maladie
c'est là que ça démarre.
Donc après il reste heu..jsp des années ou ont fais plus rien
parce qu'on est démoralisé. Jusqu au jour où
on met mon nom dans un carnet de RDV
avec le prof arnold Munich qui était un peu l éminence
qui  a été conseiller au gouvernement et tout ça
et bam on voit au western blot basique
et au final j'ai la dystrophie musculaire de Becker.
Et donc voilà, je pense qu'il a fallut sept ans
-sept ans
-de roller coaster
et le drame de tout ça c est qu'a un moment
ça a développer une espèce de complaisance avec la douleur
où plus j'avais mal et quand j'avais mal, c'est comfy parce je me disais « ha ouais enfin j'étais vraiment malade»
-Ça validait le fait que t ai une vraie maladie.
-Et ça c'est ma terreur et même aujourd'hui je pense,  j ai bientôt  30 ans et j'ai peur qu on me dise
«haha c est un pranck ou final non on s est bien foutu de ta gueule» et tout ça
ça c est ça qui m'a rendu le plus fou en fait. Et encore et toujours
même si ça va mieux
-C est le coté handicap invisible.
-Bah le
-Avec zéro diagnostic, donc pas de possibilité de dire «oui je suis vraiment malade regarde j ai ça»
-La maladie se voit pas c est un peu difficile puis surtout que moi
donc j ai connu le fauteuil roulant et tout ça donc c est venu
lors de l adolescence, l adolescence, c’était un peu la rébellion,
t'as un peu la frustration, t'es potes, ils font des trucs
y'a le skate, y'a jackaste(?) et leur merde.
T'essaye de tester les limites
mais tu vois que dès que tu vas te lever de ton fauteuil roulant
puisque tu peux marcher, c’était vraiment une putain d'aide parce que j’oubliais les douleurs et tout.
Bah les gens vont se dire «ha c'est une arnaque à l'assurance, ha tu nous ment  t'es un gros mythomane» et tout ça .
Et tout ça , ça m'a vraiment brisé jusqu'au bout quoi.
-Parce que t'as une sept ans de ce qu on apl une errance médicale
entre tes huit et tes quinze ans à peu près
-ouais, Et plus loin en fait
-Et pendant ce temps là, ton état tu disait qu'au début tu....
-Bah en fait ça dégénéré puisqu'en fait jsp les symptômes c'est vraiment des fois,
c'est lié a l effort souvent au froid
l humidité tout ça
mes muscles, si je fais un gros effort, que je vais au bout
en fait mes muscles vont lâcher un peu
ls se détruisent, donc il y a des détritus, et ça va un peu
faire overdrive donc mes muscles
vont avoir des méga contractures, ne plus marcher
faire des espèces de poussées comme ils appelles
et donc tu vois les douleurs, les douleurs, les douleurs et c'est pour ça que là j'ai commencé
à l'age de treize quatorze ans la morphine
qui est le seul recours a la douleur
que j'ai pu trouvé enfin a part des petit tips, tu prends des bains chauds des truc comme ça.
Mais sinon je suis sous skenan depuis...
tellement longtemps. D'ailleurs, si tu sais, j'en ai un peu marre de ça
parce qu'il y a beaucoup trop d effets secondaires
perte d’appétit, constipations
puis jsui fonsdé,
jsuis un junkie depuis que j'ai quinze ans quoi.
Tu parlais tout à l'heure de ce côté
peur de passer pour une arnaque.
Donc,
en gros, le regard des autres. T'as ce truc particulier :
à la fois t'es en fauteuil donc
là t'as le regard des gens sur toi directement
mais en même temps toi t'as aussi le côté où quand t'es pas en fauteuil ou quand tu te lèves de ton fauteuil
t'as aussi une autre forme de regards des gens
Pierre : Bah c'est ça // Pour toi c'est quoi
qui est le plus difficile à vivre
au niveau regard des autres dans ces deux aspects là ?
Pierre : Bah moi... Bah c'est vrai que dans les deux côtés t'as des attentes différentes.
Tant que tu es debout t'es comme ça...
Mais dès que tu es en fauteuil
t'as toujours l'image que tu dois être le bon myopathe et tout ça.
Alors que tu vois tu te dis : "Bah non, je vais peut être aller fumer des joints avec des potes, je vais faire de la merde, je vais peut être sécher les cours...
Mais tu dois toujours être le bon petit myopathe. Tu vois vraiment que si tu as des mauvais notes
avec tes profs, ils vont faire genre : Oh avec tout ce qu'on t'as donné enfin nous on a la foi...
Tu es toujours un peu le chouchou tu vois, t'es un peu la mascotte et tout et tu te dis
mais fuck it enfait enfin là je...
Enfin je vais avoir des relations sexuelles *rigole*, je vais pécho des meufs,
je veux aller picoler avec mes potes, je veux vivre des trucs comme ça.
Et ça, dans les deux côtés, j'étais genre *grogne*
Ça me rendait fou et puis...
Nan mais ce qui est le plus dur aussi avec le fauteuil c'est que
au tout début, quand les parents sont un peu cons et qu'ils voient un mec en fauteuil roulant
à côté de leurs enfants et bah... J'ai perdu tout un pan de copains comme ça.
Donc je me suis retrouvé très isolé, donc c'est là où je suis un peu tombé dans les jeux vidéos.
Dans les deux cas, dans les postures verticales ou des trucs comme ça
je m'y retrouvais pas enfait. Donc c'est ça qui
a été très très dur. Surtout que je gardais tout pour moi enfait.
Et ce que je regrette maintenant. Ouais, j'aurais dû plus en parler et tout ça mais c'est pour ça que j'étais un putain de menteur enfait.
Que je mentais à tout le monde.
Donc je voulais juste passer inaperçu et
c'est un peu chaud avec un fauteuil roulant. // Qu'est-ce qui reste le plus
pénible pour toi, pour aujourd'hui ? // Pierre : Tout ce parcours ça m'a
ruiné mais à point inimaginable enfait.
Et, enfin, j'ai eu des psychothérapies mais ultra
longues et tout ça.
Et, là, je m'en sors enfin...
Et surtout à apprendre à prendre soin de moi quoi, mais
surtout maintenant c'est tout ce parcours là,
la vision des gens.
Enfin même moi comment j'aime mon propre corps,
ça c'est le pire. Et après, les douleurs, au final
enfait ça joue sur le moral c'est sur mais je pense que c'est un peu des acouphènes
mais physiques enfait. Les acouphènes, si tu vas te dire : "Ah putain, les acouphènes",
bah tu vas entendre que ça et tu vas finir fou.
Et si après t'arrives un peu à *souffle*, à être plus sain, ça passe.
Mais après le plus difficile c'est
les nuits où ça te réveille, où tu te réveille t'es juste fatigué.
Juste entre l'échappatoire c'est que t'as pas pris encore tes médicaments
et que tu te dis : "Bah nan, je veux dormir parce que j'ai pas envie d'avoir mal".
T'as toujours des mood un peu...
Mais j'ai envie de dire que tout se passe vraiment dans ma tête au final.
// Ouais le truc qui te...
avec un peu de recul, le truc qui
t'aides le plus à vivre avec au quotidien,
c'est quoi ? //Pierre : Trouver juste des petits détails qui te sortent de toi quoi.
Enfin...
Mais c'est pas facile hein. Parce que, comme je dis, moi j'avais cette
...heu...
complaisance à la douleur et j'en ai eu du mal à m'en lâcher. Donc tu vois, je suis toujours dans mon côté
*pscht* *pscht*, ouais nan j'ai pas le droit à des trucs comme ça. Mais vraiment.
Des trucs cons, se dire : "Bah nan mais là je vais m'accorder juste
une heure de jeux vidéo", tout ça. Je dis : ouais mais nan...
Mais même se faire à bouffer enfin d'essayer de
bien manger, de trouver tous les trucs un peu comfy (confortables).
Et ça joue sur des petits détails mais c'est des minis trucs qui te sortent
de la douleur et de la...
De tout ton corps et tout ça.
Et je pense aussi
forcer la communication, au final, aussi.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose que j'ai découvert sur le tard.
Même de dire : "Ah là j'ai mal", des trucs comme ça et...
Et c'est ce qui m'a manqué pendant tout mon
parcours de santé aussi,
ne pas communiquer. Parce que tu as tellement de pression extérieure,
d'attentes...
Tu vois même tout ce syndrome d'imposture que j'ai pu vivre,
j'ai l'impression que le l'ai attisé sans le vouloir. Parce que tu vois, par exemple,
quand tu vas voir un spécialiste en biologie. Tu vas le voir
une fois tous les ans.
Et, tu vois, souvent tu dis souvent : "Bah là j'ai un rhume".
Des fois, quand je vais chez le médecin j'aurais pas le rhume, tu vois. Donc là tu vas avoir
deux mois de ton année où tu peux presque plus marcher, plus rien.
Tu vas voir le médecin, bah tu te sens bien. Mais, au final, t'as la pression
où, la "pression" entre guillemets où t'as...
t'as tes parents comme ça qui vont te dire : "Ouais tu dis bien que là tu as eu mal" parce qu'ils t'ont vu souffrir donc ils veulent plus te voir souffrir et toi, tu te retrouves
à un rendez-vous à dire : "Ah ouais ouais, j'ai eu vachement mal
là et tout ça mais je le ressentais pas physiquement mais je l'ai ressenti et ducoup, bah tout ça
je me dis : "Ah putain je suis qu'un gros menteur, je le ressens pas et tout ça".
Et tout ça. Et moi, j'aurais dû communiquer ça plus souvent enfait,
ou simplifier les choses. Plutôt que m'enfermer
dans ce système de mensonges distant. // Et du coup, tu t'es crée une espèce de
double culpabilité de ne pas aller assez mal
et de ne pas aller assez bien à certains moments ?  // Pierre : Ouais, ouais, exactement.
C'est ça qui m'a rendu le plus fou // Et ça, la psychothérapie c'est un truc qui t'as aidé ? // Pierre : Ouais, ouais, ouais. Et puis même dans la psychothérapie, j'osais pas me livrer à fond pourtant.
Parce que, je... ya...
Enfin, j'ai un parcours familial assez compliqué avec deux pans
où j'ai une mère qui a tout lâché pour moi.
Mon père, tu vois, qui étais un peu archétype sportif et tout ça donc
t'as l'impression d'être décevant, un truc comme ça.
Ya toujours un écart quoi.
Donc des gens qui vont laisser plus de place à ma vie, d'autre qui vont essayer de dire :
"Ah nan" et qui vont me mettre de côté. Donc des deux côtés ils étaient pas biens et tout ça
mais tu dois jongler avec ça. Et je me suis jamais retrouvé là-dedans
et c'est là et la psychotéraphie où je me suis dis bhin
enfait, plutôt que d'essayer de reconstruire mon passé avec des bouts
de cette personne-là, de celui-là, de ce qu'on m'a dit là... Je vais essayer de
tracer tout droit et de reconstruire ma propre réalité enfait.
Et d'accepter ce que j'étais et d'accepter que oui, donc, Pierre t'as été malade.
Et tout ça et
c'est ça. Me dire qu'à 29 ans je dois encore
dire : "Oui, c'est bon, je suis bien malade".
Sachant que j'ai eu deux western blot quand même. Western blot qui est la
un peu... on te fait la cartographie de ton génome.
Et donc, oui, je suis vraiment malade mais ya encore des fois où
j'ai peur. // Dans ton parcours, qu'il soit médical ou
perso, t'as souvenir de un jour
où quelqu'un t'as dit un truc ou donné un conseil
qui t'as
vraiment aidé à...
Pierre : Bah, vu que j'ai été con aussi, bah j'ai jamais cherché
à trouver des gens comme moi. Et c'est ce qui m'a
motivé à faire mon coming-out puisque je me suis dis : "Pierre, pourquoi tu le gardes puisque peut être
que tu vas montrer à d'autres gens que bah voilà, je suis comme vous.
Et moi je disais toujours : "Bah j'étais incapable
donc tout le monde des gens qui mourraient autour de moi
donc j'étais pas légitime et des trucs comme ça.
Et donc je me sentais pas représenté
puis j'ai jamais pu communiquer.
Enfin même, tu vois, les associations de parents
enfin où t'es toujours soit malade parmi les malades
ou des trucs comme ça donc j'ai pas envie de discuter avec ces gens-là non plus.
Donc non, vraiment, j'ai dû tout faire tout seul quoi.
Et c'est ça qui est difficile puis
enfin même pour les douleurs physiques tout ça
je fais ma petit tambouille mais heu...
Souvent, je me sens vraiment très seul quoi. J'ai pas... malheureusement non.
Et ducoup si, toi t'avais un
conseil à donner
à quelqu'un qui est plus ou moins dans ta situation ça serait quoi ?
Pierre : Bah de... ouais d'en parler
et auprès de tout le monde vraiment.
C'est comme ça que tu trouves un peu ta place et que tu fais le tri aussi.
Parce que...
Ducoup, ouais dans ce genre de situation t'as envie de satisfaire tout le monde parce que
t'as l'impression d'enlever quelque chose aux gens enfin qui m'ont donné des espoirs parce que
quand tu es valide, tu as l'impression que tu dis : "Ah, vous y étiez presque les gens, vous avez faillit avoir un truc bien" et au final non,
je suis un peu l'arnaque sur la marchandise et tout.
Mais juste vraiment communiquer à fond et c'est ça
le principal et de ne pas se cacher. Et...
de s'écouter, vraiment.
Et, heu, et puis même des fois
t'as envie de...
Bah si tu as envie de faire des conneries, bah fais-là tu vois.
Nous on paiera 10 fois plus, ya Becker, enfin...
Tu fais une soirée, bah t'en as pour une semaine. Tu boiteras
comme un putain de manchot ou tu marcheras plus mais au moins tu profites donc
vivre et faut s'écouter quand même.
Faut être raisonnable, vraiment s'écouter.
Actuellement, les traitements avec des kinés ou des cardiologues
ont principalement pour conséquence de limiter les conséquences de la dégénéraissance
musculaire mais la recherche notamment dans le domaine des
thérapies géniques donnent de bons espoirs pour l'avenir.
Ah oui, la thérapie génique, en gros c'est mettre de l'ADN
ou de l'ARN dans les cellules de quelqu'un pour régler un problème.
Pierre : J'ai un espoir quoi, j'espère que...
On voit que les thérapies géniques avancent donc j'espère que pour les kids
bah ça va aller quoi.
Et, heu...
Je suis, moi de mon côté perso... Bah là
enfin je me suis senti un peu reconnu parce que
j'étais dans un protocole donc pour soigner le coeur donc près d'une centaine
de myopathies de Beckan donc c'est cool de te dire :
"Ah ya 100 autres comme moi". Ce qui est normal hein parce que je crois qu'il y a
1 garçon sur 30 000 ou je sais pas quoi // Ouais, c'est rare ouais.
Pierre : Mais, heu, le dire : "Ah, ya une centaine de gens".
Et ducoup, je me suis dis : "Bah, moi je fais un truc pour eux, ils font un truc pour moi" donc là
on est une centaine de personnes, ça fait 4 ans qu'on se fait des IRM
cardiaques et musculaires.
Comment ça se passe ? Ducoup je me sens un petit peu important et
et il a apporté ça à mes refrès (frères) tu sais.
Mais ouais, heu, sinon, je sais pas.
Non mes seuls espoirs c'est vraiment que
...que...
le monde hospitalier
prenne un peu mieux en charge les enfants.
Et que des fois on...
c'est cool c'est que du bonheur les clowns d'hôpitaux et tout
mais ya des trucs avant enfait.
Parce que ça c'est quand t'es dans des hospitalisations longues
mais moi je me souviens, enfin, c'est mes pires traumatismes l'hôpital.
Où tu te sens littéralement un putain de bout de viande où
t'as pas de nom, t'est juste : "Ah c'est la dystrophie là" ou quoique ce soit.
Ou... // Oui, on t'appelles par le nom de ta maladie // Ouais.
// Avec plus ou moins le numéro de ta chambre. // Voilà c'est ça et puis surtout que toi
tu comprends pas puisque moi j'ai switché, j'ai vrillé d'un coup
et t'as un professeur avec l'armada de
de... de... // d'internes // d'internes.
Donc j'ai développé une putain de haine pour les internes, je suis désolé.
Mais t'es juste, t'es un kids :
il est 9 heures et demi du matin, t'as une armada
qui te foutent à poil, qui te décalottent mais on me parle de muscles.
Pourquoi vous me touchez, je peux pas montrer pas teub, vous êtes 8.
Donc t'es vraiment juste déshumanisé enfait. // Ouais. // Et après on te dit
: "Oh, on va te faire une ponction lombaire" tu sais, tu comprends pas.
T'es comme ça, t'as le truc comme ça. T'as deux infirmières.
*bruit d'enclenchement*, un truc comme ça. Le petit moment tu sais où on t'explique rien
où tu te retrouves à 3 par chambre et, heu...
La communication là-dedans c'est... Parce que tu vois j'ai
une amie
qui étais là dans une chambre avec une personne
enfin une autre enfant qui était vraiment pénible et tout ça et que nous on voyait décliner.
Elle passe au bloc, on la voit plus revenir,
les infirmières nous disent : "Ah ouais mais elle est partie", des trucs comme ça et
après on voit les parents qui vont dans sa chambre chercher ses affaires, tu vois.
Et qu'on communique rien
et ça, c'est horrible.
Et ça ça m'a rendu vraiment très très triste. Donc, voilà...
C'est cool le côté shiny, l'étoile enchantée et tout ça
mais vraiment faire plus de protocoles d'entrée dans la
"vie de malade" quoi.
Ça faut faire gaffe à ça.
Ok, Pierre. Merci beaucoup // Bah de rien.
Salut // Salut